of course I mean you know I thought we
you know you have two choices there you
know you try to make it a five-point
game where you have an opportunity to
win it with a touchdown if you get the
ball back you know or you try to you
know go for it there and then if you if
you if you happen to convert then you
got to make the two-point conversion all
the rest of it so
um you know just those are the decisions
you got to make you know I thought we
did a decent job of putting ourselves in
third down there the next series with
the defense to try to have a play to get
off the field and we just went and
handle that play very well
no no
you're going to need another possession
anyway you know what I mean so it is
it's it's not a lack of confidence you
know we went for it multiple times